Let me
edit the category.
I'll flip the screen over in just a
second.
Making sure I have everything
that I need.
So, we have what appears to be a
somewhat better result.
I fixed a couple bugs this morning on
the environment.
Uh we're still not getting like amazing
held out or anything yet though.
With the DR randomization and as well
it's nice.
Yellow 619.
I don't know if this is meaningful.
I think we can just probably grab grab
this.
Oh wait, this is a different one, isn't
it?
Oh this one is wait a second. Look at
this. So this one is 407 seconds.
>> This one is way faster.
And almost same perf.
I should just pull this. I don't know
what I'm doing. I should just pull this
whole thing, right?
Did bots meet twice in the What do you
mean did bots meet twice?
It's not like an elimination type thing.
It's just Elo.
How do you calculate Elo? You run
matches, but you just like you just run
a whole bunch of them.
You don't have to do like a tournament
style thing with double elimination.
It's more like just like a ranked
leaderboard in a game.
Yeah, that's the problem with needing
scripted agents, right?
Let's see which one I just gave it.
Now is the No, now is definitely not the
uh
definitely not the worst time to be
young.
It's a confusing time to be young, for
sure.
But that's nothing new.
>> Yeah, but it's not like if you do it
across hypers, it's not comparable,
Jess.
being on benefits and that will go do
something, right?
First of all, how slow is this?
If I actually fix this little bug.
What's the agenda? We fixed some bugs in
the environment earlier today, Jess.
And it's looking a little better as a as
a result.
Yeah, and I shall say the one thing that
probably surprised me most at um
at Stanford was that like at least 80%
of the people there basically got in by
being lucky. Like complete [ __ ]
imbeciles got in by being lucky.
And uh
instead of like actually working and
trying to learn something and make
something of themselves, they were like
entitled lazy little shits.
I actually I didn't check, but this is
fine. 3 minutes.
We'll see what this gives us.
You know, it's not increasing kind of
weird.
Anish, like that's the least of your
worries.
At least the dude worked hard at
something.
Most of the people there never worked
hard at a damn thing in their lives, and
probably never will.
Well, Jess, that's what I do now. Right
now, I uh
I get to be somewhat more insulated, but
uh when you're forced to be in a place
and surrounded by people, that's like
it's a very different story. You can't
exactly ignore your surroundings.
Like people aren't horses, you can't
just stick blinders on them.
Yeah, I genuinely think that these days,
if you want to really
do something meaningful, the best thing
you can do is to just take yourself away
from all of the noise.
Uh this Elo metric is crap. Don't even
worry about this.
This is incredibly slow.
Um
We'll see if I did this one GPU or eight
GPUs, I forget.
If it's one, it doesn't seem to be
matching what I would expect. We'll see.
Yeah, the problem is you can't really
say momentary when it's like 10 [ __ ]
years, Jess.
Like that's how long it took before I
got to start puffer.
Okay, so this is a mess.
Um
That's with eight GPUs, really?
Ow.
Wait, what?
Oh, I'm a [ __ ] Hang on.
Increasing GPUs. What do you mean?
No.
Weird.
Very weird.
Yeah, much better.
We had 20 mil SPS at least.
say I do
2 billion or something.
Once I finish crunching this.
We're trying to get self-play working
for a client
and the deadline is ASAP.
feel against its own baseline.
Yeah, so we even stuff against both, but
we don't train against the scripted bots
directly cuz it's very, very easy if you
do that.
Like
you know, whatever competitive versus
fixed opponent, yeah, we can just do
that. That's fine.
90 No, I left it at 98 because um
I need to get the the essences.
This is the side monitor content at the
moment.
Win rate timeout to pure timeout
approach win rate plus timeout.
What do you mean to pure timeout
approach Jess?
Yeah, the problem with Stanford is it's
like particular well
it's very prone to [ __ ]
There's some tool cool technical people
but there's also just like so much
[ __ ]
We'll see if this is better. This is
closer to the original intent of the
hypers.
Does have more ends though.
Um I might be able to speed this up
single buffered actually.
I'll try that next.
Oh, I see. Uh yeah Jess because
otherwise like it takes forever. There
are two reasons for that. First of all,
I want one opponent per GPU.
Right?
And um second of all like you need a
good number of games to assess win rate.
So I thought it would be simpler to just
do timeout and increase the frequencies.
We had it less frequency of less
frequent back from when it took longer
to swap the policies out.
We get lots more opponents in the
sampling now though.
Science sim env
computational fluid dynamics
Science sim env, how do you do? Well,
the goal of popper is within the next
year or so to start really doing
scientific sim.
Um we're still in the research phase of
like get RL as a field to be stable
and sane.
And uh yeah, we're probably never going
to do stuff where we put really really
expensive sim in the inner loop of
anything.
Right? We might have it as a
verification step or something.
But you cut as many corners as you
possibly can such that you still work on
the held out task.
Generally speaking.
Okay, this is not working. Does this
even replicate if I do
I mean, is this going to take forever if
I do it this way?
I think we have to just see if this
repros first.
Uh I wasn't sweeping that at the moment
just that we probably should.
It doesn't really seem to matter that
much. As long as you have some amount of
historical data, it seems like it works.
>> Well, no, we're not going to have
checkpoints.
Actually, here's what we're going to do.
I'm going to fake Robo code.
Let's do this exactly.
There.
I'm going to do it this way.
I want to get it so that we can have um
Hey Finn.
Um we had to fix a bunch of bugs in the
env
and I ran a bigger sweep and now we're
trying stuff based on fixing bugs in the
env.
We're back to sort of a simpler
approach.
I'm seeing a fixing stuff with the env.
Also a more a sparser reward function.
We're seeing if this leads to better
generalization or not.
But I think it's going to be a lot more
of an interactive loop today of me
watching
trained agents versus stuff.
How is drone going? Do you need me to do
anything to get you on track, or are you
are you set at the moment?
I was going to go and secure DOD
contracts.
I probably need to make the sweeps
multi-GPU, huh?
40 policies are similar to real life.
With ADR.
Baseline hover stronger and simple to
make it clear when transfer is good.
I'm interested how that ADR goes because
it's like
Any sort of techniques that help with
this gap will be broadly useful to us.
If you need to deploy, you can do that.
Like if you need it on real hardware.
Okay, this at least looks more stable.
So hopefully this repros.
Even though this is annoyingly slow.
>> And while this does this, once I finish
this, I will check this policy locally,
provided this is actually um
doing something versus held out.
It's actually not a unique surname at
all, depending on where you're from.
There are parts of the world in which
it's basically like Smith.
Okay, I think it just messed up our
parameters, right?
>> I just don't watch movies convert like
at all.
Oh, does it make sense that it's not
doing the uh it's not re-growing?
I want to know what the hell's happening
here.
This feels very like
uncharacteristically janky for puffer.
I know.
Like uncharacteristically jank.
I know why I changed the number of
threads, but that shouldn't do anything.
>> [sighs]
>> Yeah, it's got the right hyphens.
Yeah, weird. That's an actual repro
file, isn't it?
I don't make sense.
>> It is getting better.
But it does seem like there's still
massive decorrelation.
And this one held out.
We're going to go find out why.
The radar is super spammy. We need to um
We definitely need to improve on the uh
the drawing of that.
>> Why is it like just sitting there? It
doesn't do that versus the other one.
I don't understand why it's not It
doesn't behave this way versus the other
one.
Like just sitting on the wall?
Radar.
Uh it's not un-capped. It is quite
quick, though.
I think you can see that's about the
amount that you're supposed to be able
to get in one tick.
It's like just learning to flip it back
and forth.
It never just sits on a wall, though.
Like I don't know why it does that
versus the uh opponent.
Oh, maybe it's this. It's trying to ram.
But no, it never sits It never just sits
on a wall without being right next to
its opponent.
Okay, here's another question. Since we
did actually select this by held out
eval, if that's not remotely correlated,
Made it two doesn't even exist, I'm
pretty sure.
>> Hank can get stuck between wall.
Yeah, but I didn't see anything that was
obvious.
Um
when I was looking at the
the replay.
>> Oh, this ELO thing is annoying. We
definitely need to sweep.
We need to sweep based on ELO, as
annoying as that is.
You can't sweep on held out.
If you're back into supposed to,
let me know if it doesn't. You have to
compile it with um
You compile with CPU, and then you got
to It's a It's a PyTorch only, the CPU
back end, right?
There's an eval back end for CPU that is
um
not PyTorch, but like the training back
end is CPU with PyTorch.
>> I mean like we actually have to do
we have to run the policies against each
other to tell how good they are in the
sweep.
>> Yeah, but how are you going to feel when
I just crush it eventually, Jess?
I'm warming up to the idea that there's
actually a parameterization of sweeps
for this that makes sense.
You just have to do it in a way that's
sensible.
I basically just want default hypers as
well.
I get um
I've been cutting lately and I'm down
like I think a full 9
and it was starting to drive me [ __ ]
crazy. Like I need some damn calories so
I get plus one pastry per day.
I think I'm still in a deficit but I'm
no longer in like a batshit insane
deficit.
parametrization of sweeps
So I'm thinking just that let's say we
have eight GPUs on a box.
Each GPU is running an experiment,
right?
We allocate one GPU to just run a whole
bunch of Elo computation matches.
So while you're running the sweep, one
of the GPUs is just running Elo matches
versus all the existing checkpoints to
update their Elos.
And then is updating the um
the hyperparameter sweeps since you have
to update
its recommendations based on the new
Elos.
minus 500 minus 300. Uh yeah, I was
originally doing at least what negative
a thousand.
Last summer I did an 18 pound cut in um
6 weeks, which if you do the math,
that's a 1500 calorie like 1500 calorie
per day deficit. And I was doing that
running like 35 40 miles a week.
Now I'm doing like maybe probably 500.
Puffer lip looks cool. Should be fun.
Thank you.
Welcome.
If you're new around here, star the
puffer on GitHub. It helps us out a lot
and it's free.
Olip.
Here.
While this is running real quick, I'll
I'll show the article.
I don't really often do these, but you
know, once in a while I'm proud of
something and I kind of want to share
it.
There were very extenuating
circumstances under which I had to cut
18 pounds. Like I never get
uh 18 pounds overweight ever.
But yeah, this is from cut.
Oh yeah, here it is. So this is
46 miles 40 miles 40 miles. This is the
running block.
The long runs were just shy of 16 miles.
A whole bunch of lifting as well.
1500 calorie a day deficit.
Actually, I'm basically doing this right
now, except that I'm also I'm not being
as strict with it. So every so often
there's something else here or there and
plus one pastry.
But I did I don't weigh 185 now. So I
was probably I'm still probably at 500,
700 calorie a day deficit.
Hard to say. I'm not running as hard
though now as well. So, that's probably
why I'm like not that big of a deficit.
Right now I'm 5'9 171.
Heaviest I've been is 5'9 190.
Heaviest I've been lean or relatively
lean is probably like 180, 182 maybe.
What's the tallest you've been?
All right, this is [ __ ]
Mhm.
Trying to put weights?
Yeah, yeah.
But actually for most of my life like up
until
age 23 or something, I weighed like 140.
I was
like
That's just like called lean and don't
go to the gym.
>> I mean we're somewhere in the
neighborhood if I got a point 62
versus the scripted.
How much does it cost you to run such an
experiment with multiple games?
Wait, what do you mean?
Like the ones I'm doing right here?
Like this machine that I'm renting here
and I'm not using it efficiently at all,
but this machine is like $4.80 an hour.
Favorite soup? Oh yeah, I like soup.
I basically I eat soup 7 days a week
almost now.
Um
There's a Mexican place that does a
really good like Mexican chicken soup.
And uh then also that place is closed
once a week, so I get pho.
I pretty much can just eat soup every
day and be happy. Like
>> Oh, actually, wait. No, I I have soup
more than that, don't I? Cuz I have it
two meals a day.
I also get a minestrone in the morning.
Now I think about it, I could basically
have soup with every meal and be
A-okay.
Uh
All right.
Let's get this. Um
I just want to see if this is stable, if
this is like some quirk.
I guess you This is still not a perfect
experiment because of the learning rate
decay, right?
Uh I should have thought of that. Well,
we'll see.
Uh the reinforcement is currently
learning.
The question is whether it's learning
the correct thing against held out
opponents.
>> It's funny cuz this is supposed to be
the easy held out opponent, but it seems
like it's actually a pretty tough held
out opponent.
Yellow curve looks good.
I don't know if this thing is meaningful
at all, but whatever.
I don't know. It can't train uh
It's awful.
Okay, uh latest.
Um first I don't know.
Upper protein, late tech render on my
side is broken.
Great.
I will add that to the long list of
things to do.
There There be a polish update at one
point. Probably popper six is just going
to be like make everything actually work
fully.
duck troop
thing at the moment.
Top of the task keep.
Fixing self play.
Because this one we actually need for
client work. It also something we need
for core popper.
And but we need this for client work
ASAP and it's being a little bit fiddly.
I can tell you the sectors that we work
in.
But, I prefer not to say any details
about specific
sectors.
>> sectors. We have done work
professionally in
uh animation, commerce, finance,
defense,
gaming,
and else. There's one other one that I'm
forgetting.
And the actual self-play stuff itself
will be open source, of course.
Right?
That's kind of the nice thing about what
we do. So,
our clients are paying us to get this in
a specific application,
but since it's much, much more efficient
for us to do the self-play research on
this task anyways, than it would be
directly on the client's task, I get to
stream this. Um, the core of it will go
into Pop for it gets tested against all
our other self-play ends.
And I'm sure Jess will throw it on chess
once we have it.
Interesting though that this one is
better here.
No.
Um,
we intentionally we we keep the client
work pretty manageable.
I mean, I don't try to like I don't push
for contracts where it's not really
going to make sense or it's going to be
a bunch of [ __ ]
You know,
we have capacity to do more work, but um
we're not desperate for work enough to
take like
things that are mostly going to be a
waste of time.
Well, let's pull one of these for eval,
I guess, right?
>> Oops.
One moment.
>> All right.
We're good.
Uh
future
Would you then like to see future M's
with self-play?
Yeah, we definitely need more self-play
M's.
For sure.
It literally works for
What?
It's Anthropic's the least It's just the
most out of touch company on Earth.
Whatever.
Just ignore.
I was about to push this new policy.
Uh we will Let me go grab this.
Much more range heavy match up,
interesting.
Wait, how are they not using energy
super fast?
Interesting.
Yeah, tiny little shots, huh?
On both sides.
Can't really avoid.
>> Why did you decide to do puffer lip on
CPU?
We train on GPU and we're like an order
of magnitude plus faster than Jax.
We're also having less code.
Um, Jax has just no redeeming qualities
whatsoever.
It forces you to write terrible code.
You have to get everything. It takes
forever and even once you do all that,
it's super slow.
I think that this is mainly just being
used by researchers who don't know how
to program.
Okay, it's actually getting to be pretty
close. It's just a little bit worse than
uh
than the scripted bot.
I wonder if there's some sort of
fundamental
disadvantage that this thing has.
That's also possible.
If I were going to do some sort of self
play
you like sweep thing.
>> Well, also, even if you want to put the
game on the GPU, you still don't use
JAX.
Unless you like writing really
convoluted code that's still slow for no
[ __ ] reason.
Let me think what do I think the
probability is that this works.
Wait, this is fundamentally required,
isn't it?
>> Well, that is fighting.
Yeah, but Chulalongkorn is like
that's the guy that comes up with shitty
abstractions, right?
CPU versus CPU, GPU and so Jack. Okay,
yeah, so there is there is a substantial
case, right, where you put M's on the
GPU.
Um it just turns out that most of the
time it's not required.
Like you can just use nice parallel
multi-threading and that's already fast
and it's simpler.
Um
For things that are obviously GPU
compute workloads, then yes, they go on
the GPU. For things that have
massive observations,
maybe that goes on the GPU.
But the fun thing with our setup is it's
like
with our setup, it's so easy to just
switch to a GPU and like if you want a
naive GPU and you can basically just
replace all the the functions with their
CUDA equivalents and just like run the
ends on GPU already.
Albeit very naively, and you can
optimize from there.
One of the benefits of going lower
level.
But most of the time people submit me
GPU code, and I just like trivially copy
to CPU, and it's faster.
So, unless you actually know what you're
doing, like
you can make CPU M's very, very fast,
tens of millions of steps per second.
Well, I mean, do you really want to
implement like a very heavily branching
game on GPU?
Like, if you're writing a physics
engine, sure.
But, um a lot of M's just will hit tens
of millions of steps per second on CPU.
Okay, so let's say that we're going to
run this experiment. What else do we do
today? I think
while we are running this,
maybe we locally mess with the body
valves.
Oh, also it's not going to be that bad
because we have we have a very strong,
um
we have a very strong starting point to
seed it from.
So, I think it's not going to be that
bad.
Most off-body physics engines are CPU
heavy.
Well, it depends on what you need,
right?
It also doesn't have to be one or the
other to be fair, right? Like
I can just give you sure here compile
this Nvinkuda C, right? Whatever C and
write whatever CUDA you need.
>> I would think that this is probably
probably what we want.
Uh okay, I see.
So it actually did mess with the API. So
I think that we can consider that um
we're either gimping our bot at the
moment or the other bots are cheating,
however you want to look at it.
>> Just
Okay.
Again, I'm letting it do this because
it's an experiment.
Um
if this works
in my mind, if this works, it's worth
just spending a week rewriting all this
and figuring out how to do it correctly.
We need something that works first.
There's no point in making something
that's really good, but doesn't actually
work.
And uh it's quite unclear at the moment
what the correct form like the correct
thing is to do with self play.
But it is very clear that stuff is
non-transitive
and we need an internal eval.
So the only way I can think of to have
an internal eval is something like Elo.
And uh the only way that you can do a
sweep when you have something like eval
is to do
e- like Elo as part of the sweep. So
I think this is fine.
It's actually probably just worth
running a couple automatic checks for
just basic
fuck-ups here before we go run a full
sweep.
And we can run a couple like individual
experiments. So that's fine. I got a
couple hours to do stuff.
I think we can get something reasonable.
>> This of course writes the worst [ __ ]
code you've ever seen.
This would give you a way to sweep on
chess, though.
Arguably, you have a way higher quality
evaluation though, for chess.
So, the problem is not that the Elo
metric itself is bad. The problem is
getting a sweep type setup
with a metric that depends on evaluating
different train models in the first
place.
>> It's
tough play is tough.
And that looks like human slot, man. I
don't know.
>> No, I think it's more like reality went
over the author's head.
That could have been written by GPT.
Well, no, GPT-2 was not even like
coherent.
I hope um who was the contributor
violent glitzy or whatever who was uh
going to take a look at protein over the
weekend. That'd be nice.
Yeah, game theory's got just too much
Nash for my liking.
Nashing of teeth.
Yeah.
I have a few more things to check before
we can actually run this.
Uh this is all off This is all awful
garbage code.
This is for an experiment.
I do think that we need some form of Elo
evaluation and sweep.
Well, hang on. There is one other form
we could do of this, I suppose.
The other could do is we could try um
We could do the same Elo evaluation, but
we would not include other policies
from
the sweep in the checkpoint.
Be cleaner, but probably what much
worse.
Hopefully, we can just run something
quick though with this to see.
So, the experiments are going to be
Elo as the core metric for sweeps.
All right, and it's going to be
self play historical self play for each
experiment versus
Uh each experiment is self play versus
other policies in league.
Which does have some annoyances that go
with it.
We'll test that for sure.
If we don't need to do crossplay with
these,
it's much much better for us, I would
say.
Right?
Yes.
It is much better.
If we don't need to do crossplay cuz if
we have to do crossplay, we kill our
ability to do architecture search at the
same time
with any reasonable amount of
simplicity.
>> The shitty event loop thing that the uh
game sets up
made a mess of things. Fix that.
I'm going to best to just remove that,
honestly.
Um
No.
I don't really think that there was much
there.
Um so the point here right is we have a
we have
a sweep.
Final checkpoints from each experiment
go into a pool.
New experiments play some fraction of
their games against opponent sampled
from this pool.
This should give us quite a bit of
robustness, but then also we will have a
process dedicated to evaluating Elo
among all of the uh the different
policies.
And then we'll see by the end of a sweep
what is max Elo and then how you to what
extent Elo
correlates with held out performance.
Yeah, I think it's fine that we do it
this way. And then I have I'll have
things I can do locally
>> I'm letting it just do all these stupid
tests. Again, this is like
not
great, but
quick way to prototype this.
That's actually kind of annoying in some
sense.
I do think that for the most part Dario
is being honest.
He's just like completely [ __ ] out of
touch.
So,
having the most normal sounding guy that
lies a bunch is not necessarily the uh
the fix.
>> I mean, I guess I like Dario more than
Altman in the sense that like
at least he's telling you how batshit
crazy he is instead of just lying about
everything.
But to be fair, I think probably Altman
is not as batshit crazy. He's just like
businessman that lies a [ __ ] ton.
I don't [ __ ] know.
How about they both [ __ ] off and we just
put Demis in charge of everything?
>> So, I think that the main problem with
DeepMind, which I guess you would
probably if you talked to the right
person there, you'd be able to bridge,
is um
they have a really, really bad
like disconnect between their research
and engineering.
I get the sense that they're kind of
just like telling their like the
scientists are kind of just telling
their engineers what they need and then
like not understanding whatsoever.
Like they don't have the engineers
making enough decisions, I think.
A lot of their like best papers would
have been 10x better if the engineering
weren't so utterly embarrassing.
And they wouldn't need to have all these
super fancy methods, either.
Still, I mean, you got to hand it to
them, right? Like if you were to just
list the top 10
most important works in RL, they have
several of them.
That's cuz the Google always wants to
have their own system, like
I remember when it was TensorFlow,
like everybody had their own different
wrapper of the damn thing cuz nobody
wanted to use it the way it was.
That's more so Google making everybody
do things their way.
Hide and seek and Dodo were both open
AI.
In my mind at both of their peak eras,
um open AI had the better RL results,
the better RL approach, and it wasn't
even close.
But then they stopped doing it.
Yeah. I mean, I was there in I think
2018.
I was at open AI for 6 months.
Back then it was awesome.
You know, I would not have I'd have
basically nothing negative to say if it
were the same place
today as it was then.
It's not.
Genie go anywhere?
No.
Not for this type of RL at the very
least.
We do know that somehow it We know that
it's shaped like a puffer fish.
I have no idea what that means, but it's
shaped like a puffer fish.
minor
Um
It's dumber than a smart undergrad.
And write substantially worse code as
well.
No, so like the prompting thing is just
brain damaged.
There's no prompting skill. It's mainly
just like
No, you not knowing anything means you
don't know how to ask a read like a
well-formed question.
Where you make dumb assumptions. It has
nothing to do with the AI whatsoever.
Yeah, see I know that's not remotely
true.
Like yes, the open AI employees use
their own tools in working on
the model, but that's completely
different from saying that the model
itself just designed the next version.
If that's what happened, open AI
wouldn't have so many damn employees.
versus self-improvement Yeah, I think
that that's probably I mean just that's
a good problem to explore with state
sets in a way.
Cuz it seems like kind of improbable to
be able to do that without state
state sets.
I mean, when you have like a really
long-form game that's not that doesn't
really get that much harder over time,
you'd basically want to see linear
completion progress with
training compute.
I mean, just imagine that you get the
Pokémon Red train curve, right? Which
like percentage of game completed and
it's like linear or better with compute
invested.
I mean, in some sense, the way that you
know that um
these companies are nowhere even close
is the fact that they're just like
frantically trying to buy each other's
employees every other month.
And uh a good chunk of their employees
aren't even that smart anymore. They've
really dropped the talent density.
They do still have some of the best
like the best researchers and engineers
in the world,
but it's no longer remotely like uh a
big fraction.
>> Where's the talent density?
Well, it's not like there was never
talent density at a big company, right?
The talent density was from when the
companies had like 100 or fewer people.
Yeah, but meta kneecapped themselves
like
they have a whole bunch of
organizational issues.
I mean, literally all you need in order
to um
to at least have a competent team is to
hire like you literally just need to
hire the right 10 people, give them
compute that [ __ ] works, and get the
hell out of their way.
Most of the most talented people I know
are just doing their own companies now.
And then the failure mode there is like
raising too much VC and having too many
strings attached.
It's not going to bring down the
economy. It's like
it's a bubble in the sense that the the
internet was a bubble, right? Like the
internet was the most important thing
ever, right?
And it was still a bubble.
Same thing now.
AI does some stuff. It's very, very
useful. It's a big deal.
No, it's not literally God. No, it
doesn't solve everything. And no, just
adding more compute isn't going to fix
all the core problems with it.
This is very obvious.
Only not obvious if you've been spending
too much time on X
or on SF, same thing.
We have one GPU devoted to
matches. That's going to be low
efficiency.
Rest of them should be high efficiency
relatively.
Looks good.
No, AI as a whole isn't a bubble, but
this whole like a throw increasing
amounts of money at language models
definitely is.
Um I suppose you are right that you
would probably that you probably will
end up with some sort of recession over
um
over the tech bubble at some point.
There is a massive massive overextension
of capital. That is true.
You're not going to break the country or
anything, though.
Well, I I there's some nice bits to
this, right? Like we are getting
accelerated chip development as a result
of this.
Um that is actually genuinely useful.
Arguably, some of it's been in somewhat
the wrong direction, like
we don't actually
like outside of the giant models, we
actually don't really care about VRAM
that much and um
we have other requirements
that are not being pursued quite as
much, but I mean, we are still getting
nice
pretty solid new uh improvements to
chips at a good pace.
Um yeah, they're getting more and more
expensive, but that's mostly just like
the massive demand. They will eventually
come down and get cheaper again.
Like they'd always done before.
>> And so this is suboptimal, but not
horrendous.
Freedom man, you have not said a single
coherent thing all day.
I I I do seriously recommend just
spending less time on the internet and
like going outside or something.
I mean, like seriously, look at what
you're writing.
Well, I mean, if you if you trust the
LLM so much, literally just paste what
you're writing into any of the models
and ask if it's remotely coherent.
And even if the guy was at one point at
recent, that's incredibly [ __ ] sad.
>> I will say I do actually know like
legitimately
uh many talented researchers that have
basically just gone nuts
with LLM's.
Well, I think that for some of them
being in SF and doing a lot of acid has
uh
a lot to do with it as well, frankly.
I don't know what if any of you've been
around um or if any of you are in SF,
but there's very distinctly there's a
type of person in SF that was like
once very smart, but pretty miserable,
and then suddenly a few years later
they're uh like genuinely seem pretty
happy and to be doing well, but like the
stuff they say is complete incoherent
nonsense.
And they'll actually some of them are
still very good speaking and stuff, and
like if each individual sentence sounds
fine, but if you put the whole thing of
what they're saying, it's like, wait,
what the [ __ ]
I think it's just a combination of it
being a really, really big echo chamber
and then drugs.
You taking substances, drugs?
No, I I mean, I drank more than I should
have in college, but that's about it.
I mean, I shouldn't say that's about it.
That's literally it.
Nootropics?
No.
I mean, I have a variety of like pretty
normal supplements.
Yeah, it's
The way I describe it is like
it's like the um
you know, the cigarette ad agencies kind
of smelled the money in it and they they
just moved in.
That's kind of the best
way to describe what's happened.
Okay, do we have some experiments in
here?
Kind of.
Sweet, we're living the dream. Not
really.
What do I take? I mean I mostly just
have supplements for digestion and
stuff.
My stomach's um I've had some issues
with
various things.
Actually, this is kind of funny, right?
So, this is
This is the Elo of the first model,
which should be strong. This is we what
we expect.
The second model somehow ended up
showing like this shows up stronger and
then we have a bunch of weaker ones. So,
this is pretty much what we expect.
I can set something up locally in the
meanwhile the meanwhile, right?
This is actually not as bad as I
thought. It's mostly the privileged
information use.
That'll be a
Been there before, though.
I'm awful at chess.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
We pretty much just have this here.
The main thing.
So, I suppose the question is do we
improve substantially or not over the um
the initial policy.
Unfortunately, these are like these are
much longer and more irritating
experiments to have.
Which is why I didn't want to have to
have that's this way in the first place,
but um
>> Okay, so I guess then the big question
would be what? Um
if
ELO-based evaluation
I think that the thing that we're very
likely need to keep, we keep the
ELO-based evaluation regardless.
And then the question will be whether or
not we need to have the uh the pool
of opponents or not.
What is this?
This is me waiting on experiments for
PufferLib.
We currently have
seven different GPUs running
experiments,
training policies, and then we have one
GPU that is running
matches between those policies
calculating ELOs.
And then that is being used to inform
what an experiments to run next.
The setup is pretty irritating though
because like
Okay, I guess if we end up with a
version of this where
you don't need to mix in the other
policy data for this sweep,
then it's still efficient.
Actually, we'll be able to run that task
pretty easily.
Right terminal, that this is just Codex.
I'm just using it to prototype a bunch
of dumb experiment code.
The main thing we have to figure out at
the moment is it once we get the version
of this algorithm that works.
I'm basically going to have to scrap all
the shitty Codex code and rewrite it.
But, the key thing at the moment is like
what is the
form of this algorithm that
works?
Oh.
Congrats to uh
Congrats to Jacob.
60 mil seed funding for Foresters Lab.
Probably the best lab in in RL.
If only I can convince him to stop
jacking everything.
>> Okay, I actually I have been just
staring at this for the last 15 minutes,
but I do at least have one thing that
I've come up with in the process.
So,
when we finally get when we get the
final model for this, right? We'll end
up with a model that is the highest Elo
of everything.
Which actually currently nothing is
meaningfully improved over the first set
of hypers.
Though our
sweep algorithm is expected to take
quite a few runs to get started.
We will what we'll be able to do is
assuming that we end up with a number of
good models trained.
We will take the hypers
of the best training run.
And then we'll train pure historical
self-play.
We can train pure self-play and we can
train with population of opponents.
From the sweep.
That should be a good enough experiment
to tell us which of these we need.
And hopefully it ends up being the
simple one.
>> 4 p.m.
I'm trying to think if there's anything
else I can do that's like isolated from
this.
This Elo experiment, I think, was the
important thing from today. This is
correct.
We had some good bug fixes this morning,
as well.
You know, give me a second to go walk
around a little bit. I'll be right back.
Um if you're new around here, star
Puffer on GitHub. It helps me out. I'll
be right back.
>> Okay.
So,
I think um I think we're at a good
stopping point honestly for today, guys.
Um
I pretty much I have the key experiment
running. I've come up with ways such
that once this is done, we can run all
the core ablations
that I need to run.
Um it's going to be a few hours. I have
one other RL thing I need to do
off-stream.
So, I think what we're going to do is
we're going to just I'm going to let
this run. I'm going to sign off.
And then I think we should be able to as
long as we at least get a few policies
that are better than the one that we
started with here.
I guess that's the only key risk is
maybe this whole thing is screwed up,
but uh either way within a couple
iterations of this, hopefully by
sometime tomorrow we'll have this.
And then we'll be able to run these
policies against each other.
We will be able to train a new policy
using these to start it and using the
optimal hypers.
Uh we'll be able to compare that to pure
self-play.
And we'll be able to compare that in
both Elo versus other agents. We'll be
able to compare it
against scripted held-out bots.
And that should give us a pretty solid
idea
for this technique.
Okay.
Um
for everybody watching, thank you very
much for tuning in today.
Probably be streaming more tomorrow most
likely.
If you're interested in my stuff
generally,
puffer.ai, everything's open source.
Star Puffer on GitHub helps us out a
lot.
Discord to get involved with
development, and you can follow me on X
more often.